hi there today we're looking at neural
architecture search without training by
Joseph Miller Jack Turner amis Torquay
and Eliot J Crowley on a high level this
paper performs neural architecture
search by looking at the correlation
matrices of the Jacobian of the of the
data when you pass it through the
network and it does so at initialization
so you pass the data look at the
Jacobian and if it's very correlated
then the network is bad and if it's very
uncorrelated then the network is good
and by simply observing that they can
already achieve a very good score on
neural architecture search benchmark
alright that was a high level and maybe
a bit too simplified but that's sort of
what's going on ok let's dive in so
what's neural architecture search neural
architecture search is the discipline of
you are given a data set let's say here
we have a data set which could be
something like C 410 which is an image
data set and you are given a sort of a
training procedure let's say Adam or SGD
for 100,000 steps or something like this
with many batches of size 64 ok and
you're given a loss function which the
loss function here could be the cross
entropy between the outputs of the
network which we'll call L and the label
Y and your task is now to find a neural
network architecture that conforms to
these specifications but gives the
lowest possible loss or de sorry the
highest possible validation accuracy in
this case so this here would be like the
Train and then you'd have the test
accuracy or the validation accuracy okay
so you could decide well I'm gonna go
with you know first like three
convolutional layers each one having
like a real ooh non-linearity but you
could also say well I'm going to build
like a skip connection from here to here
you could also say that I'm going to
down sample by
you could have maybe a bigger stride and
so on so the kernel size of the
convolution you can vary until now
people have done this by hand right in
effect we all use like the same 10 to 20
different architectures so if it's an
image problem we tend to go for like a
res net or a wide ResNet like a vgg
style architecture someone has come up
with those at some point with each of
those discover that it works well and we
don't really do much exploration we
simply kind of use the same things over
and over and the the truth is that there
might be much better architectures that
were simply not exploring right there
might be much better building plans for
networks that we don't know of that
might perform a lot better with the same
data and the same training so neural
architecture searches the process of
automatically searching for these better
architectures of course that's a
combinatorial problem but the idea is
that you know you can actually learn to
construct good architectures and by
doing so you can you can sort of speed
up this process that is manual otherwise
and the idea behind it is there some
regularity of when an architecture is
good there's some like high level of
pattern that you as a human maybe cannot
really grasp but like a machine can
figure out which architectures are good
and which ones aren't so there have been
a few inventions in this in this area
but they are mostly costly that's what
they say here the time and effort
involved in hand designing deep neural
networks is immense this has prompted
development of neural architecture
search techniques to automate this
design however neural architecture
search algorithms tend to be extremely
slow and expensive they need to train
vast numbers of candidate networks to
inform the search process
so what neural architecture search
methods do is what they'll have is
they'll have something like a controller
in the controller itself of course is
going to be a neural network
so there'll be this thing that will be
the controller and the controller will
emit like a building plan so the
controller will emit like a building
plan for this network right here and
then you train the entire thing once
through for the entire hundred thousand
steps and then you observe the final
validation accuracy which might be
something like eighty percent and then
you know okay this is eighty percent so
you feed the eighty percent into your
controller and the controller out puts
the next building plan that it thinks
will score higher and then you train the
entire thing again and you maybe observe
a 70% accuracy you again feed that in
right and the controller realizes oh I
may have done something wrong let me try
something else
and does it yet if this looks like
reinforcement learning to you that's
because this is reinforcement learning
so there really is see here the
controller would be the agent the
percentages here the accuracies would be
the reward and the invasions would be
basically this thing here this thing
would be the actions but sometimes it's
the observations and you need to score
the different things okay so the problem
of course with this is that the
reinforcement learning requires a lot of
data it requires a lot of steps to
converge because the signal from the
reward is just so weak you simply get
one number for your action and you don't
know what you can change to make it
better you simply have to try so you
need a lot of steps but this thing here
is mighty slow because each each single
step in your reinforcement learning
procedure involves training an entire
neural network for like this many steps
ok so all of this is ginormously slow
and resource intensive and that of
course blocks a lot of research because
you know we started with the plan to
automate this part right here
but automating it itself is super
expensive so they go for a different
solution they say this could be
indeed if we could infer at Network
sorry if we could infer a networks
trained accuracy from its initial state
okay it seems a bit out there but let's
let's give them benefit of the doubt in
this work we examine how the linear maps
induced by data points correlate for
untrained network architectures in the
NASA bench 201 search space and motivate
how this can be used to give a measure
of modeling flexibility which is highly
indicative of a network strained
performance we incorporate this measure
into a simple algorithm that allows us
to search for powerful networks without
any training in a matter of seconds on a
single GPU okay and they have the code
available right here if you want to go
and check that out so let's go in let's
go into that the claims are pretty big
and the reasoning behind the claims is
the following observation you can
already sort of see in this graphic
right here we'll we'll go over what it
means in one second but what they do is
they take different networks in this
search space and the search space in
this case is given by this benchmark so
this benchmark basically has a long list
I think of architectures that you could
consider actually so it's a it's a
constructive list so they don't actually
give you the list but they give you like
a a way to construct architectures and
they took those architectures and they
rank them by how well they score on C
410 so there are very good architectures
which are here there are good ones there
are mediocre ones and then the bad ones
okay and you can see that the histograms
here of whatever they measure they look
quite different so the histograms with
the good ones they all have kind of
spiky around zero and the histograms
of the bad ones all sort of look spread
out so this is the measure that they're
going to propose is they have some sort
of number some sort of histogram that
they produce and if the histogram is
very spiky and close together
around zero then they conclude that this
network is good and if the histogram is
very spread out like this they conclude
that the network is bad now these
histograms as you might expect they are
computed not from the final trained
Network but they are computed from the
initial Network so here they show at
least you know in this case it seems to
be that there is a general correlation
between the trained accuracy and how
this histogram looks and we're going to
explore what they do so
it's essentially it's pretty easy they
compute the linear map around each data
point so what is that if you imagine a
neural network as a nonlinear function
which I guess you should because it is
so let's imagine it as like a nonlinear
function from X to Y what they'll do is
simply they'll look at a given date
training data point which could be here
right this could be the X and this could
be the the Y and in fact let's look at
it in lost landscape not even in Y but
in L in terms of the loss because we
don't need necessarily a single label
this could be for unsupervised this
could be for anything okay so it Maps a
data point to a loss now what we'll do
is we'll simply linearize the function
around that point which means we'll just
freeze all the nonlinearities in place
and that will give us this linear
function right here okay we just observe
that this linear function can exist it's
the tangent to the lost landscape and
it's at a particular data point right
it's in data space not in in weight
space then we look at a different data
point so we look at this data point
right here another data point
what's the linear function around this
one is sort of like whoops T is like
that and then around this one is like
this okay so this is one function now
let's look at a different function
right here so L X and we'll look at this
function the linear function okay so for
some reason this is like this and if we
consider two data points their
linearization is very similar
now imagine that these two have been
produced by the same sort of neural
networks it's just the architecture is a
little different but they have been
produced like they have the same number
of parameters in the neural network
which neural network would you prefer
remember you can in by training the
neural network you can actually shape
this loss function you can kind of shape
that around so which one would you
prefer I personally would prefer the top
one because the top one already tells me
that hey you know I might have 10
parameters here and this already sort of
looks like each of the 10 parameters is
doing something so if I then go into my
10 parameters and I you know turn this
knob right here then I might you know up
this bump or down this bump or do
something with it but the sort of
frequencies curvature the randomness of
the function the way that it fluctuates
tells me that all of the different
parameters must have some sort of effect
right because it's of quite an
expressive function whereas if I have
the same number of parameters for a
function like this this sort of tells me
well maybe only one of the when we only
one of the weights is actually doing
something maybe only one of the
dimensions is doing something this seems
odd right that even though I've
initialized it randomly a super regular
function like this comes out so maybe
all of the all of these parameters down
here they don't do anything or it is so
somehow the signal doesn't get through
so that's I they don't explicitly say it
in these terms but this is how I make
sense of this what they're saying is
that if you look at the linearizations
of the function
and you look at the the angle right here
so the angle in this case is that and in
this case is that and in this case is
that so you look at the slope here and
the slope is basically the gradient of
these linearized functions and what you
want to do is you want to look at the
correlation between those of the
different data points so here you have
three angles one is very short one is
very bit longer like this and or no even
like this and one is even over ninety
degrees like that they are not
correlated at all right they're all very
different
however the angles here they're all
quite the same as you can see so what
they propose is the following let's send
all the data points or in that case all
the data points in a particular
mini-batch let's send them through the
function and let's calculate their
linearizations so the linearization is
nothing else than you send them through
the network to obtain the F value for
the x value and then you calculate the
gradient with respect to the input now
you have to get used to this a bit
because usually we calculate the
gradient with respect to the weight but
now we calculate the gradient with
respect to the input which if this is a
linear function so if you have a live f
of X equals WX like a linear function
then this gradient del F del X would
just give you the W will give you the
slope of the linear function and the
same in the neural network when you
linearize it alright so we're going to
obtain all these linearizations and that
gives us the this matrix J right here
and what we can do is we can then
observe the covariance matrix of J of
all these linearizations the covariance
matrix simply tells you how to data
points vary with each other and in fact
they don't look at the covariance matrix
but they look at the correlation
matrix which is simply the scaled
covariance matrix so one entry in this
covariance matrix so you have n data
points and this gives you a matrix
that's n by n and that particular entry
here like the entry IJ would simply
state how does the angle of data point I
correlate with the angle of data point J
okay that's the that's the covariance
matrix and now the hypothesis is if all
of these data points are sort of
independent like in our very expressive
function here then the these
correlations they should not be high in
fact most data points should be rather
uncorrelated however in this case right
here if the function is sort of kind of
degenerative or something not very
expressive then all of these all of
these angles or of these linearizations
should be highly correlated and that's
what you see in this graph right here
this right here now is these correlation
histogram of the correlations between
local linear maps across all pairs of
items in a mini batch of C 410 training
data each pod is a histogram for a
single untrained na s bench 201
architecture so remember the
expressivity is important because we
want to train that function and
therefore it's important that every
parameter does something and if it's
degenerate we can't train it well and
that's I find that's the reasoning they
they sort of say this but not I might
make I might make the wrong sense out of
it here but it seems to me like that's
what's actually going on so you can see
this is simply these matrix values
rolled out and then plot it as a
histogram so what does it mean when the
histogram is like super spread out like
this it means that there are a lot and I
think down here our axes yes there are a
lot of data points that correlate highly
or anti correlate highly with each other
okay which means that exactly this
degeneracy happens
either too high or too negative high
correlation means that they're very much
they're kind of the same thing so there
is if you have as many parameters as
data points that means that one
parameter can potentially serve these
two data points or these two that are
correlated by one or negative one you
don't need both parameters and therefore
you have a lot of parameters doing
nothing whereas over here with the good
networks you can see that this spikes
around zero meaning that the data points
are not correlated or the linearizations
around the data points are not
correlated and therefore you can sort of
shape the function around each data
point however you want which we sort of
know that neural networks what they do
is they're so over expressive that
they're actually able to shape the
functions around the data points without
necessarily looking at other data points
nearby and that expressivity is what
what you want and that expressivity is
what this in part measures okay so they
make a they have some experiments here
where they validate this so for all
these architectures in this benchmark
and maybe I should tell you what show
you what the benchmark looks like so the
benchmark has this particular form this
particular form there's this skeleton
and in this skeleton there is this block
and it's always repeated and you're
basically your task is to determine what
this block should be so this block has
an input node a and an output node D and
two intermediate nodes and what you have
to do is basically you have to determine
these connections right here so there
are six connections and for each one you
have the option of putting different
things there like you can see you put
can put a convolution you can put the
identity function which is a skip
connection zero eyes I'm I don't maybe
that's the zero function so it basically
means nothing I'm not so sure
honestly but you could technically put a
convolution here and here right or and
or different convolutions or things like
this so there are
these 15,625 possible cells okay so the
nurse benchmark contains 15,625 possible
architectures that you'll have to search
and they take these architectures and
they plot now they plot for each
architecture the validation accuracy
after training and the training protocol
is standardized you don't have to care
about that right and the score that they
measure at the beginning of training and
what you can see is that there is a
linear relationship sort of like a sort
of from from these experiments what
you'll get is like this sort of feeling
what they're gonna propose is that you
should take that score as a as a measure
and here again also sword of sword sword
of there is a there is a clear trend as
you can see right here though yeah
though this as you can see this sort of
spreads out and the most right one is
imagenet which is the most difficult one
of course so and this is C for 100 which
is more difficult than C for 10 so we
can see that this sort of relationship
at the top it doesn't really hold
anymore if the task gets difficult and
this is so what I think is happening
this is kind of an interjection of my
own opinion what's happening here is
that this score that they discover
allows them pretty efficiently to see
which networks are just degenerate and
and cannot be trained like if you try to
train them they just perform really
poorly okay that it's probably a very
good score for weeding those out and
that would mean if you kind of barrier
here somewhere right you could just
discard a whole lot of this crap or even
even here right you could just discard a
whole lot of this crap and also now here
just you know all of this crap yeah
whereas here as you can see some of this
score sometimes it's higher
then these ones even though they perform
better and again you could probably
discard a lot of the crap but it's not
as distinctive for the well performing
networks because these here are all not
the degenerate version right they're not
degenerate in the sense that they're
they have some fundamental flaw where
the function lakhs now expressivity from
the very start so you can't train it and
then probably other factors come into
play
other factors then you can simply
determine with this particular score but
you know there there is this
relationship that's that's you know you
can see that and they do some ablations
on this here for example or your score
is a proxy for a number of parameters
and they say no the number of parameters
works way worse than this particular
score which it always is a cool thing
then how important is a specific
mini-batch and initialization and they
say look right here we for some
architectures we do different mini batch
sizes and you can see each of those
groups they don't vary too much in how
their it influences their score this is
I believe this is the same architecture
so it's always an architecture that
achieves in this case for example wow
that's a not a straight line 77% or so
and you can see if you go for different
mini batches the score varies only
minimally initialization is a bigger
variance inducing thing but also here
the scores don't vary too much but it is
interesting that the different
initialization to get you to different
score because it would directly support
kind of my hypothesis now what's going
on here is that you sort of measure
initial degeneracies and you can sort of
make up for these initial degeneracies
in the architecture sometimes with sort
of a different initialization so the
different initializations
give you differently performing networks
we already know this from things like
you know a lottery ticket hypothesis and
so on that the initialization can
matter to some degree in these types of
things now
that being said they always train to the
same it seems but their their score
varies so I might be backwards correct
here or not correct but in any case the
initialization here matters more but
also you can still see this linear
relationship and this is particularly
interesting this is even the case when
you just input white noise so instead of
the data you measure that score by just
inputting noise that I guess has some
sort of the same magnitude as the data
would have but it's just noise and you
can still sort of see this linear
relationship which is very interesting
and that I think also shows some that
you what you'll find what you find is a
property of the network itself and the
fact that it is it is initialized and
built in such a way that it allows you
to train it in a very in a sort of a
benign manner it has no degeneracies
okay so in last experiment they go here
and they say we evaluated the score on
initialized networks in the PI torch CV
library so they go to this library that
has a lot of these networks but these
networks are not the same as this
benchmark this benchmark is specifically
designed to do architecture search now
the networks in this library they are
all designed to perform really well some
are designed to be quite small some are
designed to be quite fast and so on but
in general they're all of their goal is
to perform well and they have been sort
of found by humans to perform well
so they take now these networks on C 410
and they test them so as you can see
here here is the test accuracy again and
here is their score that they give it
and they say rip it up put it up now I
can't move this anymore
hello well okay
they say that this linear relationship
still sort of holds it doesn't it
doesn't hold super super well but you
can still sort of if you squint if you
squint hard you can see that it sort of
goes upward though you really have to
squint hard like what are these things
right here and what again what's the
case is that if the score is low you
will sort of be able to cut off the cut
of the worst-performing ones but really
at the top here it doesn't seem like
there is a particular relation between
between these networks and this initial
score which sort of strengthens my
hypothesis that what this does is just
kind of weed out the bad ones but it's
pretty cool because you can weed out the
bad ones without any training right it's
simply forward prop backward prop there
you have it so cool now they come they
here is the experiment where they now
really do this na s benchmark and they
compare with other methods so some of
these other methods are designed to do
they call it weight sharing which
basically is a technique where you can
sort of speed up the speed up the
algorithm as compared to non weight
sharing and the non weigh cheering
that's one of these we have discussed
initially that was my initial example
with the controller and so on where it
takes super long so here you see the
method and how long each method takes
now the best ones as you can see already
the best ones here are these these
methods right here are the best ones
they score somewhat like a 93.9 or so on
C 410 whereas these weight sharing ones
they don't perform too well except this
one seems to perform quite well and in
this hour's case they perform worse than
that but they still perform better than
a lot of the weight sharing
once so what their point is basically is
that they get a pretty good score which
is a ninety one point five on C for ten
which is you know it's at least not
degenerate it's a it's a good accuracy
they score that with simply evaluating
ten architectures right and as n goes up
as they evaluate more and more
architectures they do they do get better
but not much so they have a discussion
here I'm having trouble moving this all
right so we'll sort of go through the
discussion we report results yada yada
yada yada
as the set up the non weight sharing
methods are given a time budget of
twelve thousand seconds for our method
and the non weight sharing methods are
averaged accuracies or averaged over 500
runs for weight sharing methods
accuracies are reported over three runs
with the exception of G das our method
is able to outperform all the way
chairing methods while requiring a
fraction of the search time and that you
maybe see at the table this is the real
I mean this is the real deal here they
only use here one point seven seconds
compared to the twelve thousand seconds
of the other methods and you reach
almost the same accuracy now to be said
two percent in this particular regime on
C 410 is still a sizable difference and
that's the same benchmark right with the
same sort of the same training schedule
and so on so there's not too much room
to tune here you simply have to find a
better architecture so these things are
still sizably ahead of this and what it
appears to me that these methods here
that don't perform well they're they're
simply crap it seems they're simply I
don't I don't know but they might be
trying out something or you know doing
something researchy or whatnot but it
seems like if you're well able to weed
out the bad architectures you might be
getting to a score like this and then if
you are
actually performing a search to find the
best one then you might be getting to
somewhere like this and you can see this
here throughout so in C for 100 they
achieve a better score than these things
but a worse score than the non weight
sharing method and an image net it gets
even the difference is even larger so
again what I can see here is that
there's is a good method to maybe get
you like let's say 90% of the wear of
the way you want to go and what's
interesting is that here they say we
also show the effect of sample size we
show the accuracy of the network's
chosen by our method for each n so
that's the sample size we list the
optimal accuracy for sample sizes 10 and
hundred and random selection over the
whole benchmark so in this case they
have the the optimal one which I guess
they just draw 10 samples and then take
the best one so they train all of them
and then take the best one you can see
that already gets you to the 93 and
whereas in their case sometimes when
they add more they get worse so here
they get better but then they get worse
again so they comment on this right here
we observe that the sample size does not
have a large effect on the accuracy of
our method but note that as sample size
increases our method suffers from a
small amount of noise increasing the gap
between our score and the optimal result
and of course the key practical benefit
is execution time so again they are
massively faster than the other methods
but to me it seems you could just think
of combining these methods right you
combine this with this in that what you
want to do is actually actively search
for the best ones but by doing so you
could if you could pretty quickly weed
out the bad ones using this method down
here you might already have like a big
speed up because again with comparison
to this random ones what appears to
happen is that the
get good at finding you know you're 90%
architecture but then they fail to
differentiate the top performance
performers from each other where you'd
really have to train the network to find
out what's you know which one's better
so yeah here they say they visualize the
trade-off between search time and
accuracy for C for 10 for different NES
algorithms on dnas benchmark by removing
the need for training our method is able
to find accurate networks in seconds
instead of hours and here you can see
the accuracy and here you can see the
time and all the the good ones are
either way over here or here and there's
is almost at zero while being quite
close to the accuracy of the other ones
all right yeah that was that was this
paper again I think this is pretty
valuable if you are especially if you're
in a new domain where you might not know
what kind of network to build you might
just be able to write a little script
that generates networks run it through
this algorithm and at least you get an
idea of which ones are certainly not
worth considering and then you can
simply select one of the other ones it
doesn't you know often it doesn't need
to be the best ones and you can then
tweak it a little bit manually the ones
you found may be you see some regularity
and yeah that was my two cents on this
paper I hope you liked it if you did
consider sharing it out and telling your
friends about it and subscribing liking
and leave a comment if you agree or
disagree that was it
bye